yes president Donald Trump is pushed on
the brink of being impeached within the
past hour the House Judiciary Committee
has voted to approve two articles of
abuse of power and obstruction of
Congress against Trump
mr. chairman there are 23 eyes and 17
nose your article is agreed to the
resolution as amended is ordered
reported favorably to the house all
Democratic controlled House of
Representatives will vote next week on
whether to formally charged the
President and send them for a Senate
trial Trump's accused of breaking the
law by withholding aid to pressure
Ukraine and to investigating political
rival Joe Biden today is a solemn and
sad day for the third time and a little
over a century and a half the House
Judiciary Committee has voted articles
of impeachment against the president for
abuse of power and obstruction of
Congress the house will act
expeditiously thank you we'll go to our
White House correspondent Kimberly how
kitten just a second but first let's
talk behind a Joe Castro who's live on
Capitol Hill and hide he just catches up
on what happened and what's been decided
hey Julie so yesterday couldn't have
been more of a marathon of a partisan
debate session and this morning the very
opposite the quickest action we've seen
on Capitol Hill with those votes coming
first thing after the gavel was struck
this morning and then a very quick
statement as you just heard from
chairman of the House Judiciary
Committee Jerry Nadler but this is a
historic moment and there has been weeks
of build-up to it as you heard now let's
say this is only the third time in US
history that a president has had an
impeachment proceeding progress to this
extent against him and these two
articles that have just been passed by
the committee are abuse of power and
obstruction of Congress both linked to
the accusations against Trump that he
was pressuring Ukraine to launch imbed
nations into his political opponents in
exchange for security aid and for a
White House visit to the president of
Ukraine Trump this whole time has said
that he is not guilty of any wrongdoing
but Democrats have argued that there is
compelling and even damning evidence
from more than a dozen witnesses as well
as the phone transcript the partial
transcript that shared with the American
public the president's own words asking
the president of Ukraine for a favor
those investigations into Joe Biden but
where we at now in the greater context
well next week the full house which is
of course controlled by the opposition
party the Democrats will then look at
these same articles and all signs are
that they will pass they have the
numbers to do so at that point Trump
would be formally impeached and then
looking into the new year
the Senate will hold a trial to decide
whether or not to convict Trump of
either or both charges if he's convicted
he would be automatically removed from
office it is notable that no president
in the US has been removed from office
from impeachment Nixon had resigned
before it got at this point in the
process and so many are asking Democrats
especially faced with the reality that
because Republicans control the Senate
and because their majority leader there
has already said there is quote no
chance Trump would be removed then why
are Democrats even going to do this in
the first place well the response has
been that this is the constitutional
duty of Congress to oversee the
president and Democrats have even said
that they would feel complicit in
Trump's wrongdoing if they were to not
do anything at all Julie hiding Joe
Castro there live with the latest on
that from Capitol Hill thank you well
let's go to our White House
correspondent Kimberly halket and so
Kimberly they've had in our faster 14
hours of debating those amendments on
Thursday and I guess we've seen Trump be
extremely vocal haven't we and part of
the tone of that seems to be let's just
get on with it
I think the headline here Julie to be
really clear is history has just been
made on Capitol Hill and this is a
president who sees this as a stain on
the legacy that he says he's been
fighting for in terms of his agenda for
the American people's statement coming
from the White House press secretary
Stephanie Grisham just in the last few
moments this desperate charade of an
impeachment inquiry in the House
Judiciary Committee has reached a
shameful end the president looks forward
to receiving in the Senate the in the
Senate the fair treatment and due
process which continues to be
disgracefully denied to him by the House
of course that coming in advance of the
full House vote next week where we do
expect that the president will be
impeached along party lines but this is
a White House in a fighting mood already
we know there's been reporting that the
president's close ally and personal
friend as well as legal adviser Rudolph
Giuliani who of course his own name has
been brought up in this Ukraine
impeachment inquiry repeatedly for
conducting shadow diplomacy outside of
the regular channels also causing from
problems for the president is apparently
here at the White House the White House
not saying why he's here or what they're
gaming in terms of strategy but we do
know that there is a difference of
opinion between the president and his
allies here on the White House campus
and the Republicans up on Capitol Hill
this is a president that wants a swift
trial he wants to be able to call
witnesses the Republicans on Capitol
Hill on the other hand want to see
something very quick no calling of
witnesses because they want to quickly
acquit the president but this is more
than just the acquittal this president
not only does he seem to want to clear
his name he also wants to get out
information on his political rival
namely the fact that they want to call
the witness hunter Biden the son of
president former Vice President Joe
Biden who of course in has been drawn
into all of this as a focus of that
phone call between the u.s. president
and the Ukrainian President Vladimir
zalenski back in July so this is
certainly something that we are getting
a sense increasingly that the president
feeling personally aggrieved by this
very thin-skinned we know fighting back
in a fighting mood were watching very
carefully
as he has some public events moving
forward whether or not he will speak
about this as he has been tweeting
pushing back claiming no wrongdoing on
social media Kimbra he'll get there live
from washington d.c kimberly as always
thank you